bien monsieur le garde des sceaux
monsieur le président la commission des
lois mais mes chers collègues en
préambule je tiens vraiment à remercier
le président françois noël buffet de
cette audition en matière
constitutionnelle
rappelons qu'il s'agit d'une première
révision constitutionnelle dont la
commission d'aménagement du territoire
et du développement durable a à
connaître nos collègues députés ont
adopté sans modification le 16 mars
dernier le projet de loi
constitutionnelle que le garde des
sceaux a patiemment défendu dans
l'hémicycle et dans les médias force est
de vous reconnaitre monsieur le garde
des sceaux une grande force persuasive
talent que vous avez certainement forgée
pendant vos années de plaidoiries les
révisions constitutionnelles sont des
temps forts de l'activité parlementaire
le législateur n'ayant que rarement
l'occasion de revêtir les habits du
constituant quand il le fait surtout au
sénat c'est avec rigueur sérieux et sens
critique les dispositions
constitutionnelles irrigue non seulement
tout notre droit et son interprétation
par les juges mais disent également
quelque chose des valeurs communes
partagées par l'ensemble des citoyens
celle qui fonde notre contrat social il
importe donc que chacun perçoivent ce
que tout changement constitutionnel
implique et comment l'ordre juridique en
serait modifié la constitution est un
tout tout cohérent
chaque disposition s'apprécie à l'aune
des autres principes constitutionnels
le projet de révision qui nous occupe
aujourd'hui porte sur l'insertion à
l'article 1er de notre constitution
d'une nouvelle phrase qui dispose que la
france garantit la préservation de
l'environnement et de la diversité
biologique et luttent contre leur ai
dérèglement climatique monsieur le garde
des sceaux nous avons à décortiquer avec
vous cette phrase cette unique phrase
mais chaque mot de celle ci compte
d'autant plus qu'elle a vocation à
figurer au sommet de notre hiérarchie
des normes à la place symbolique de
l'article 1er celui les plus imminents
principes de notre pays sont affirmés
cet article agit comme un miroir qui
renvoie l'image de la république à
l'ensemble des citoyens
pour paraphraser montesquieu sa
modification ne doit pas être faite que
d'une main tremblante à l'issue d'un
raisonnement qui lui ne tremble pas
telle une analyse littéraire littéral il
nous faut pesé au trébuchet de les
implications de chaque mot de cette
phrase en particulier la force de chacun
des deux verres qu'elle contient car il
recèle des risques contentieux et ouvre
l'accès au prétoire constitutionnel a de
nouveau type de requérants
il importe que la représentation
nationale puisse débattre de
l'articulation de nouvel étage des
droits environnementaux avec les autres
principes constitutionnels consacré par
notre texte fondamental
monsieur le garde des sceaux nous vous
laissons un peu mon collègue présent la
commission des lois la parole pour
présenter au public exigeant que sont
les sénateurs
la réforme constitutionnelle que vous
portez au nom du président de la
république monsieur le président de la
commission des lois monsieur le
président de la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable monsieur
rapporteur pour avis
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs alors on nous assistons à la
sixième extinction de masse des espèces
vivantes du pour la première fois à
l'action humaine gouvernement entend
être à la hauteur des enjeux auxquels
nos générations et des générations
futures sont confrontés c'est la raison
pour laquelle le gouvernement souhaite
inscrire à l'article 1er de notre loi
fondamentale que la france garantie
la préservation de l'environnement et de
la diversité biologique et lutte contre
le dérèglement climatique
c'est une réforme ambitieuse qui
consiste à rehausser la place de
l'environnement dans notre constitution
et de la place est au coeur de toutes
nos politiques publiques compte tenu de
l'urgence climatique de l'urgence
environnementale le gouvernement entente
en effet fixé aux pouvoirs publics des
obligations plus importante que celle
qui existe actuellement
comme vous le savez la protection de
l'environnement est un principe inscrit
dans la charte de l'environnement
résultant de la loi constitutionnelle du
1er mars 2005
cette charte mentionné dans le préambule
de notre constitution fait pleinement
partie du bloc de constitutionnalité le
conseil constitutionnel a
progressivement par sa jurisprudence
fait produire à la charte le maximum de
ses effets juridiques
ce dernier a ainsi jugé dans sa décision
le 31 janvier 2020 la protection de
l'environnement ne constituait plus un
simple objectif d'intérêt général mais
un objectif de valeur constitutionnelle
qui est de nature à justifier les
limitations apportées par la loi à
d'autres exigences constitutionnelles et
notamment à la liberté d'entreprendre
toutefois et vous le savez bien sûr un
objectif à valeur constitutionnelle
à la différence d'une règle
constitutionnelle ayant un caractère
impératif ne comporte aucune obligation
de moyens et nécessite pour sa mise en
oeuvre
l'intervention du législateur un
objectif à valeur constitutionnelle ne
peut pas davantage être invoqués à
l'appui d'une question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité
le projet de révision constitutionnelle
que nous vous soumettons en érigeant la
protection de l'environnement et la
lutte contre le dérèglement climatique
en véritables principes constitutionnels
entend aller plus loin que les textes et
la jurisprudence actuelle
tout d'abord l'inscription de ces
principes à l'article 1er de notre
constitution représente une valeur
symbolique forte
proposé par les membres de la convention
citoyenne lors d'un exercice inédit de
démocratie participative que les choses
soient claires il ne s'agit pas
aujourd'hui d'opposer démocratie
représentative et démocratie
participative
je l' ai déjà dit dans le cadre d'autres
débats et je pense que renforcer la
démocratie participative ce n'est pas
affaiblir la démocratie je crois au
contraire que plus nos concitoyens
seront associés au débat public plus la
légitimité de ce qu'ils éliront sera
renforcée surtout qu'il ait des enjeux
qui doivent pouvoir nous réunir et le
climat ont fait partie en effet la
préservation de l'environnement et de la
diversité biologique la lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique doivent désormais
être au coeur de nos politiques
publiques
je souligne cet égard que la charte de
l'environnement et muette sur ce dernier
point
je tiens à préciser que le gouvernement
n'entend toutefois pas introduire
d'échelle de valeur entre les principes
constitutionnels
demain comme hier tous les principes
constitutionnels seront de valeur égale
c'est d'ailleurs pour ce motif que le
président de la république a décidé de
ne pas donner une suite favorable à la
proposition de modification du préambule
de la constitution qui avait été
présentée par la convention citoyenne
pour le climat l'objectif est en réalité
de donner plus de poids à la protection
de l'environnement dans sa conciliation
avec les autres principe à valeur
constitutionnelle que nous connaissons
je tiens également à préciser qu'il ne
s'agit pas davantage de créer un
principe constitutionnel de non
régression des lois en matière
d'environnement
un tel principe existe dans la loi mais
il n'a pas sa place dans la constitution
le gouvernement on veut en effet laissé
au législateur le pouvoir de préserver
efficacement d'autres principes
constitutionnels comme par exemple la
protection de la santé dans un contexte
de crise sanitaire quelques celui que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui cela peut
être particulièrement important
toutefois le gouvernement entend fixer
un véritable principe d'action des
pouvoirs publics nationaux comme locaux
en faveur de l'environnement et de la
lutte contre le dérèglement climatique
c'est dans cette optique et en
conscience que l'article unique du
projet qui vous est soumis prévoit
d'inscrire à l'article 1er de la
constitution que les pouvoirs publics
doivent garantir la préservation de
l'environnement et la diversité
biologique ainsi que lutter contre le
dérèglement climatique
les conséquences de l'emploi de ces
verbes ne sont pas neutres et elle est
bien la volonté du gouvernement
parfaitement conscient des impacts que
cela pourra avoir sur l'engagement de la
responsabilité des pouvoirs publics en
matière environnementale il s'agit de
mettre à leur charge comme l'a souligné
le conseil d'état une quasi obligation
de résultat j'insiste sur ce point car
je sais qu'il a été en débat lors de vos
précédentes auditions et je rappelle que
ce sont les mots employés par le conseil
d'état aujourd'hui déjà la préservation
de l'environnement doit conditionner
l'action des pouvoirs publics et la
responsabilité de l'état peut être
engagée à ce titre je m'en tiens à deux
exemples récents peut citer l'arrêt du
10 juillet 2020 par lequel le conseil
d'état a ordonné au gouvernement de
prendre des mesures pour réduire la
pollution de l'air sous astreinte de 10
millions d'euros par semestre de retard
je pense également au jugement rendu par
le tribunal administratif de paris le 3
février 2021 à propos de l' affaire dite
affaire du siècle
le tribunal a reconnu vous le savez
l'existence d'un préjudice écologique
lié au changement climatique
il juge que la carence partiel de l'état
français à respecter les objectifs qu'il
s'est fixés en matière de réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre engage
sa responsabilité
ce projet de loi constitutionnelle
consacre encore davantage cette
responsabilité des pouvoirs publics en
promouvant la protection de
l'environnement au statut de garanties
constitutionnelles comme vous le savez
le texte du projet de loi
constitutionnelle a été débattue à
l'assemblée nationale pendant près de 20
heures
elle a été adoptée en l'état la semaine
dernière il vous appartient de débattre
sur ce projet qui comme vous le savez
bien sûr s'il est adopté par les deux
chambres dans les mêmes termes seront
ensuite soumis aux français par la voie
du référendum conformément à
l'engagement de notre président de la
république
c'est pourquoi
mais l'homme les sénatrices messieurs
les sénateurs je suis heureux et honoré
de débattre de tout cela aujourd'hui
avec vous merci monsieur le ministre
peut-être tout de suite monsieur le
rapporteur pour avis il fait relier la
parole merci monsieur le président
monsieur le garde des sceaux en tant que
représentant de la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable on aborde l'examen
de ce texte sont ou dix ans qu'on est au
sein de cette commission toujours
mobilisés et on agit et on cherche à
favoriser la préservation de
l'environnement et à agir pour la
préservation aussi et la reconquête de
la biodiversité face à ce projet de loi
constitutionnelle on l'a malgré tout un
certain nombre d'interrogations puisque
comme vous l'avez rappelé nous disposons
depuis 2005 d'une charte de
l'environnement qui a déjà pleine valeur
constitutionnelle donc la première
question il y avait déjà en partie
répondu c'est l'intérêt de la révision
constitutionnelle au regard des
dispositions qui existent déjà et qui
sont déjà constitutionnaliser on
comprend que cette réforme c'est relève
d'un symbole fort de l'inscription d'un
nouveau principal article 1 de notre
texte fondamental donc
qu'attendez-vous de cette
constitutionnalisation et des effets
juridiques supplémentaires et
l'affirmation de ces deux principes
d'action à deux endroits de notre
constitution at elle pour but contre 1
la carence des pouvoirs publics et du
législateur et qui mesurera l'efficacité
les actions menées en faveur de la
diversité biologique et pour lutter
contre le dérèglement climatique n'est
ce pas avec
cette réforme donner un pouvoir
d'appréciation accrue aux juges
vous l'avez évoqué le mot les mots ont
leur importance dans une phrase unique
qu'elle est là prescriptive it et
juridique du verbe garantir n'est ce pas
ouvrir le champ à de nouveaux types de
contentieux environnementaux qui livrait
il imiterait l'appréciation du
législateur quand il a la charge
difficile de concilier des objectifs
parfois contradictoires et ne pensez
vous pas que la france seule peut
garantir sur des sujets aussi vastes que
les questions climatiques et enfin sur
l'avis du conseil d'état que vous avez
ok qui fait état d'une quasi obligation
de résultat est ce que c'est pas
susceptible d'entraver liberté d'action
pour nos entreprises sur le territoire
national et ses dispositions ne sortent
elles pas une une hiérarchie implicite
implicite par nom des principes à valeur
constitutionnelle
voilà un certain nombre de questions
merci je permettrai de de compléter ou
de venir en appui de ce qui vient d'être
dit l'introduction à l'article 1er
du verbe garantir naturellement doit
être interprétée en tous les cas un sens
de lui être donnée dans le droit des
contrats ainsi en matière civile que
nous connaissons habituellement ou plus
facilement la distinction obligation de
moyens obligation de résultat nous la
connaissons le moyen c'est tout mettre
en oeuvre pour obtenir le but que l'on
s'est donné l'obligation de résultat
c'est d'obtenir le résultat que l'on
veut mais vraiment l'obtenir et la
garantie c'est à coup sûr d'y aboutir or
vous dit vous avez déclaré en tous les
cas que la rédaction telle qu'elle était
proposée par le gouvernement était
instaurait une quasi obligation de
résultat donc à un moment il faut qu'on
choisisse en tous les cas on a besoin
d'être éclairé sur le sens qui est donné
par le gouvernement sur sept ce verbe
garantir
car selon soit il est une obligation de
moyens et il ya un sujet c'est une
obligation de résultat il ya un sujet
aussi il ne peut pas être entre les deux
et on a besoin de savoir exactement le
sens que vous donnez un la notion de
quasi obligation de résultat je pense
que ça c'est un point qui pour nous nous
interroge sachant que si tel est le cas
et que c'est une obligation absolue les
conséquences juridiques ensuite par
rapport au législateur s'est lui cette
heure peut parfaitement être sanctionné
par le conseil constitutionnel sur le
fait de ne pas respecter ses hommes
cette notion de garantie et de surcroît
cela pourrait laisser entendre que le
conseil constitutionnel serait ta
décisionnaires de tous et deviendrait le
juge du quasiment du travail législatif
au delà même de la protection de la
constitution elle-même
on a besoin d'y voir clair sur ce sur
cet aspect des choses sites antiques moi
même je le sois voilà ce que je voulais
vous vous demandez et peut-être monsieur
vers des sceaux de profiter pour donner
encore la parole à quelques-uns de nos
collègues
je pense en particulier à monsieur
philippe bonnecarrère et ensuite à
madame nadège avait oui merci monsieur
le président on remercie monsieur le
garde de sceaux de cette audition la sim
sur le résident de me donner la parole
ce qui me permet de m'inscrire dans la
continuité des questions que vous avez
posées autour
monsieur garde des sceaux de la quasi
obligation de résultat et du contenu
d'une réforme que vous nous avez
présenté comme ambitieuse ce qui me
conduit à deux questions
première question quels sont les
nouveaux champs quels sont les nouveaux
champs de responsabilités qui seront
ouverts par cet article 1
si la révision va jusqu'à son terme
et si oui pouvez vous nous donner des
exemples de ces nouveaux cas de
responsabilité puisque si la réforme
c'est que il y a un intérêt qu'on va
aller au delà de la jurisprudence du
conseil d'état lequel vous avez fait
référence donc quelles seraient les
exemples de nouveaux champs de
responsabilité et en avez vous évalué le
coude pour les pouvoirs publics c'est à
dire pour l'état et notamment pour les
collectivités locales
deuxième question qui en est le
corollaire avez vous fait un recensement
des textes des dispositions législatives
qui au visa de ce nouvel article 1 sont
susceptibles d'être déclarées
inconstitutionnelles et pouvez vous nous
donner des exemples des dispositions qui
tomberait à la nouvelle lecture de
l'article merci de
vos réponses à ces deux questions
monsieur le ministre merci chers
collègues un visio je vais donner la
parole à madame avait bonjour bonjour
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
ça vous poser une question permet tout
d'abord de saluer les travaux réalisés
par la convention citoyenne qui ont fait
un travail remarquable avec des mesures
ambitieuses
depuis 2005 une charte de
l'environnement existe elle a été
reconnue par le conseil constitutionnel
en 2008
celui ci indique l ensemble des droits
et devoirs définis par la charte de
l'environnement ou valeur
constitutionnelle et s'imposent aux
pouvoirs publics et aux autorités
administratives dans leur domaine de
compétences respectives
pouvez vous nous dire quel serait
l'apport d'une inscription de
l'environnement dans la constitution je
vous remercie
merci madame madame brigitte lherbier
et puis ensuite monsieur monsieur dantec
et après on donnera la parole aux
monsieur le garde des sceaux même
lherbier monsieur le garde des sceaux
compléter la constitition pourriez
intégrer des principes de préservation
de l'environnement et lutter contre le
dérèglement climatique est une très
bonne idée en soi en phase avec notre
temps et les enjeux à venir
on ne peut que s'y soumettre je me
demande néanmoins si cette modification
de la constitution aura une portée
normative et si c'est le cas je craint
d'éventuelles conséquences pour les
entreprises françaises
déjà soumis à une rude concurrence
internationale savoir si elles seront
soumises à de nouvelles obligations non
reprise par les pays concurrent
économique voisin et
je suis inquiète pour ses entreprises
parce que nous sommes dans une période
difficile il faut prendre garde de ne
pas encore les handicapés alors que la
période que nous vivons est déjà
extrêmement difficile pour elle alors
qu'en sera-t-il monsieur le garde des
sceaux et le cas échéant y aura-t-il des
possibilités d'aménager à la plus ou
moins long terme leurs obligations le
quasi chien merci j'ai donné ma parole à
un ronan dantec
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre je voyais que au début
j'avais été plutôt sais pas si le terme
séduit le bon mais en tout cas interrogé
par le fait qu'un certain nombre de
constitutionnalistes disait tout ça ne
sert à rien au vu des réactions que
suscite la phrase aujourd'hui au
contraire j'ai vraiment l'impression
qu'il est plus qu'urgent en décrire
cette phrase dans la constitution
est-ce qu'on voit bien à travers les
interventions y compris encore cet après
midi qu'il y à encore et chacun
évidemment tout à fait libre est
légitime de ses opinions
une partie de la représentation
politique peut-être derrière de la
société française qui ne veut pas mettre
la société française en situation de
reconquête sur les grands enjeux
environnementaux alors qu'on sait très
bien que s'il n'y a pas cette reconquête
c'est l'avenir même des générations
futures voire de nos enfants actuels 1
qui est menacée donc
donc je pense qu'effectivement pour une
fois que le gouvernement reprend une
proposition de la convention citoyenne
je crois que vous avez fait oeuvre utile
donc ma question est assez simple
monsieur le ministre
est-ce qu'à partir du moment où le débat
montre bien qu'il est bien nécessaire
d'écrire ainsi des choses dans la
constitution vu les inquiétudes qui
s'expriment
est ce que le gouvernement sera ferme
sur ce libellé ou est ce que une version
édulcorée
est encore une possibilité et si
monsieur dantec monsieur le ministre on
vous donne la parole et puis ensuite je
redonnerai la parole d'abord à monsieur
waterblez ensuite mais madame préville
monsieur bah mman bonne foi monsieur le
ministre
merci monsieur président de la
commission des lois
d'abord une réponse commune si vous le
voulez bien
à l'attention de monsieur le sénateur
chevrollier et de madame la sénatrice
avait c'est la même question qui est
posée que je peux résumer de la façon
suivante sans trahir j'espère votre
pensée auquel cas bien sûr vous le dirai
pourquoi ne pas se contenter du droite
actuelle là au fond la question vous
posez tout d'abord l'inscription de la
préservation de l'environnement à
l'article 1er de la constitution je l'
ai dit tout à l'heure présente une
valeur symbolique très forte elle a été
voulue par les membres de la convention
citoyenne je ne me rappelle pas je redis
ici que il n'y a aucune raison d'opposer
les uns aux autres il s'agit ensuite
très clairement de renforcer le poids
constitutionnel de la protection de
l'environnement
j'ai tout à l'heure dans le discours et
vous avez reconnu
je vous en sais gré que j'avais déjà
pour partie répondu à votre question
distinguer les différentes les
différentes analyses
la règle constitutionnelle d'un côté son
caractère impératif est l'objectif à
valeur constitutionnelle qui n'a pas la
même force
il s'agit d'instaurer un véritable
principe d'action des pouvoirs publics
c'est l'engagement du président de la
république et de gouvernement ensuite
évidemment se pose la question je n'ose
pas la dire sempiternel mais elle a été
évoquée à de très très nombreuses
reprises qui m'a fait dire d'ailleurs
que en réalité ces 18 mo l'article 1er
si on considère que le l apostrophe est
un mot et nous y avons passé plus de 18
heures une heure par mo en réalité ça
n'est pas vrai nous avons passé dix huit
heures sur deux mots garantir et lutter
alors je veux rappeler ici parce
qu'évidemment j'ai déjà entendu ces
remarques bien sûr mais qu'est ce que
c'est qu'une quasi obligation de
résultat c'est d'abord les mots qui ont
été choisis par le conseil d'état
lui-même
c'est à mon avis pardon un plus qu'une
obligation de moyens et moins qu'une
obligation de résultat mais ça
s'approche de l'obligation de résultat
c'est à dire que tout doit être fait
pour
comment on peut encore décliner les
choses d'abord je voudrais vous rappeler
que évidemment le gouvernement a pris
connaissance de l'avis du conseil d'état
et le gouvernement a souhaité aller plus
loin que la norme constitutionnelle
qui existent en introduisant une
véritable obligation d'action positive à
charge des pouvoirs publics
qualifié de quasi obligation de résultat
par le conseil d'état et ce risque nous
souhaitons le prendre la maison brûle et
pour reprendre l'expression du président
chirac il y à bien longtemps de cela
des choses ont été faites incomplète en
ce qui concerne la charte et j'y
reviendrai le moment venu
notamment sur le dérèglement climatique
nous jetons aller plus loin parce que la
maison brûle encore plus et que
l'incendié a consommé une partie de la
maison
donc il ya à la fois une volonté
politique est me semble-t-il une
nécessité d'aller plus loin et monsieur
le sénateur bonne carrière je ne peux
pas vous dire ce qui sera sanctionnée
comme étant inconstitutionnelle par
définition parce que je n'ai pas comme
qualité la médiumnité mais je pense que
le législateur fera attention comme il
le fait habituellement de ne pas voter
une loi dont il pourrait a priori penser
qu'elle est inconstitutionnelle c'est la
première chose
quant aux collectivités locales
l'article 34 de notre constitution
confie à la loi la fixation des
principes fondamentaux de la
préservation de l'environnement
la garantie qui est posée par le projet
de loi pèse d'abord sur l'état et
ensuite vous fait ce geste et il est
tout à fait et évocateur de la réalité
si bien sûr une collectivité
territoriale violent les obligations qui
pourraient elles pourraient engager sa
responsabilité mais en citant tout à
l'heure dans le discours de deux procès
déjà que nous que nous connaissons que
nous connaissons tous
nous voyons qu'il existe déjà un
contentieux et qu'il y a une vue
ici à risation mais la volonté je le
redis c'est d'aller plus loin on a prêté
un certain nombre d'arrières pensées
nous y nous en reparlerons sans doute le
le moment venu moi je crois
véritablement que l'environnement est
désormais une préoccupation à laquelle
j'ai envie de dire personne ne peut se
soustraire
il ya ce que nous allons laisser à nos
enfants et nous nous rendons contre tous
les jours il suffit de regarder la météo
pendant des mois pour avoir comment
dirais-je une situation tangible sous
les yeux situation qui d'un point de vue
climatique par exemple se dégrade ce qui
n'était pas le cas quand la charte a été
a été a été envisagée même si on pouvait
pressentir un certain nombre de choses
de ce point de vue d'ailleurs je sais
que certains ont été visionnaire mais
des années plus tard il faut aller plus
loin voilà le sens de de ce texte et
voilà ce que à cet instant je peux je
peux vous dire je peux vous dire sur les
à propos des questions qui ont été
posées sur la rédaction est ce que le
libellé peu bougé voilà ce qui m'a
demandé c'est toute la dernière question
il bougera si le sénat estime qu notre
rédaction est préférable c'est moi je ne
peux pas imposer les deux mots auxquels
je tiens c'est vous qui votez
ça n'est pas moins et fort heureusement
mais la rédaction que nous proposons a
été adopté par l'assemblée nationale
cette issue de la convention citoyenne
et ça correspond exactement au
renforcement souhaité par le
gouvernement voilà ce que je peux
exprimer de la façon la plus simple la
plus franche et la plus directe auprès
d'eux merci monsieur le ministre alors
la parole est à monsieur dany wattebled
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
garde des sceaux bien sûr qu'en tant que
nation nous devons tous
la prévention d'environnement comme vous
l'avez dit de les serrer un monde
d'après nos enfants mais l'attention du
gouvernement d'inscrire la défense
environnement dans at-il promis la
discussion est louable mais réformer la
question n'est pas un acte anodin alors
que la protection de l'environnement est
déjà consacrée par le produit le veulent
avait rappelé de la caution que la chair
l'environnement 2005
ce changement apporté à notion interroge
à plusieurs titres comme des sensations
et conseil d'état d'abord la difficile
interprétation qui résultent de ce
changement les effets de l'utilisation
du terme garantir et où l'avait rappelé
sur les objections du résultat
et voici mes trois questions d'abord
quels sont les effets juridiques 4 dont
le gouvernement se serait fonctionnel
vous avez un espérer une partie pourrait
vous complétez pouvez aujourd'hui nous
garantir que le principe de préservation
de l'environnement ne prendra pas le pas
sur la défense des libertés publiques ou
d'autres droits comme le droit au
logement ou le droit à la propriété et
surtout ce changement constitutionnel
va-t-il pas consulté du nouveau
contentieux qui bloqueront tous projets
futurs que ce soit pour les d'urbanisme
de économique l'autre car dans la
crainte je pense que personne ne bougera
merci madame près mille merci monsieur
le président monsieur le garde des
sceaux
donc je partage effectivement compte que
se soustraire à l'impératif d'agir
vu la situation actuelle et je partage
aussi que la valeur symbolique c'est
toujours quelque chose de très fort et
c'est un signal important qui est envoyé
à toute la société
alors moi j'ai d'abord une petite
question parce que c'est
ce qui est sans doute pas grand chose
pourquoi diversité biologique et pas
biodiversité donc et puis d'autre part
garantir est-ce que garantir la
diversité biologique alors que comme
vous l'avez dit on assiste à la sixième
extinction est ce que cela sous-entend
que toutes mesures législatives à venir
doit faire en sorte que cela ne
contribue pas à la perte de la
biodiversité
et qu'est-ce qui fera foi en l'état
pour ce qui est de lutter contre le
dérèglement climatique
est ce que c'est la même chose c'est à
dire que par exemple toutes mesures qui
ne seraient pas conformes à la stratégie
nationale bas carbone puisque c'est ce
qui va nous permettre de lutter contre
le dérèglement climatique est ce que
c'est ce qui va arbitrer en fête et
notamment puisque vous avez juste un
petit peu parlé du droit d'entreprendre
et j'aurais voulu savoir comment ça
s'articule est et après j'ai noté une
petite nuance alors on a parlé d'
obligations moyen de résultat et vous
avez parlé d' obligation d'action est ce
qu'il ya une différence entre action et
moyens voilà je remercie merci madame
par l'état monsieur philippe bas merci
beaucoup monsieur le président j'entends
bien à travers toutes les questions qui
sont posées qu'il ya quand même parmi
nous beaucoup d'interrogations monsieur
le ministre sur la conciliation entre
les principes et vos réponses ne m'ont
pas complètement rassuré sur ce point
puisque cette quasi obligation de
résultat elle signifie au fond qu'on va
faire quand même prévaloir la
préservation de l'environnement la
préservation de la biodiversité sur le
progrès économique et social
or j'ai lu dans l'article 6 de la charte
de l'environnement que la définition
même du développement durable c'est la
conciliation entre ces principes donc je
me demande si on peut laisser coexister
l'article 6 de la charte
de l'environnement avec votre
proposition d'article enfin d'alinéa
ajouté à l'article 1er de la
constitution parce que je suis bien
d'accord je crois que c'est même une
règle de base du droit constitutionnel
que il faut concilier les principes
encore faut-il que leurs rédactions
elle-même n'écartent pas cette
conciliation mais en vérité comme vous
êtes amenés déjà à répondre à ces
questions puisque d'autres collègues
vous les ont posées
moi je voudrais vous poser une question
qui n'a aucun caractère juridique et je
crois que vous avez amorcé la réponse à
ça le sénat a le choix entre trois
solutions
il adopte comme l'assemblée nationale
sans abonnement sans amendement alors là
le président de la république a déjà
annoncé la couleur
c'est le référendum mais le sénat
pourrait aussi rejeté sans autre forme
de procès le texte alors est-ce que je
peux considérer qu'à ce moment là la
révision constitutionnelle s'arrête là
et il pourrait être troisièmement c'est
une voix tout à fait envisageable et qui
correspond assez bien à l'esprit
constructif des sénateurs amendé votre
texte est-ce que c'est à prendre ou à
laisser
est ce que si nous allons dont votre
texte le texte du sénat sera inscrit à
l'assemblée nationale pour poursuivre le
processus de révision constitutionnelle
sur ce point nous n'avons pas encore
entendu la parole publique ni du
président de la république ni du
gouvernement est évidemment selon votre
réponse
nous saurons à quoi nous en tenir sur
l'utilité de notre travail
merci monsieur bah écoute
en visio nicole bonnefoy oui bonjour
chaque collègue monsieur le ministre le
sénat et plus particulièrement le groupe
socialiste a déposé une proposition de
loi constitutionnelle le 10 décembre
dernier visant à introduire la notion de
bien commun dans l'article 1er de la
constitution
si lors du débat en séance sur cette
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
un ministre de l'environnement a rejeté
notre proposition
force est de constater que le texte que
vous nous présentez au mois de mai s'est
inspiré de nos travaux et c'est tant
mieux
l'intention du gouvernement dans son
exposé des motifs et bien de favoriser
la protection de l'environnement la
diversité biologique et la lutte contre
le dérèglement climatique
il paraît donc nous partageons les mêmes
objectifs
cependant monsieur le garde des sceaux
nous n'y mettons visiblement pas les
mêmes moyens en effet la proposition de
modification de la constitution que nous
avons proposé donc en décembre dernier
était plus ambitieuse puisqu'elle
intègre et les biens communs mondiaux ou
encore les biens communs informationnels
nous considérons en effet que les enjeux
de protection de nos doyens commun
environnementaux sont absolument
capitaux pour notre début de ce siècle
il est donc nécessaire d'aller plus loin
et je note par ailleurs que votre
gouvernement et la majorité avaient
eux-mêmes à l'assemblée nationale a
rejeté systématique systématiquement les
amendements tenant à renforcer le texte
aussi alors que vous ne l'avez dit tout
à l'heure il fallait aller plus loin
monsieur le garde des sceaux est ce que
vous allez à accepter les améliorations
que le sénat pourrait apporter sur ce
texte au regard des travaux que nous
avons déjà engagé sur le sujet et
deuxième question dans le contexte de
crise sanitaire alors que se pose la
question du report des élections
régionales et départementales en jeu
comment peut-on envisager la tenue d'un
référendum dans le cadre prévu par la
constitution
merci pour votre réponse merci madame
je me donne la parole monsieur le
ministre monsieur le sénateur water il
est branché
oui monsieur le sénateur wattlebled
d'abord je voudrais je voudrais vous
faire remarquer que le mot garantir
figurent déjà à plusieurs reprises dans
d'entrée en bulles de la constitution
notamment sur la santé en ce qui
concerne la santé et ses principes et
concilier avec les autres nous l'avons
dit je je j'ai eu l'honneur de de le
dire d'emblée dans le mot liminaire qui
que j'ai prononcés il ne s'agit pas de
hiérarchiser les normes non mais ce qui
permet de de rassurer certains
sceptiques si j'ose dire parce que il ne
s'agit pas de ne plus entreprendre il ne
s'agit pas de ne plus faire un certain
nombre de choses nous savons que
l'activité humaine par essence et par
définition peu pollué d'ailleurs
monsieur le sénateur bas c'est quelque
chose que vous savez bien puisque déjà à
l'époque de la charte ces questions là
ont été posées et j'ai eu la curiosité
d'aller voir ce que vous disiez à
l'époque et ceux qui se trouvent
évidemment consignées dans les débats
sénatoriaux et c'est exactement ce que
je vais dire si si si je puis faire cet
emprunt est élu sénateur en 2011
monsieur le ministre
oui c'est en 2014 c'est en 2014 où vous
évoquez la charte
je vais vous remettre le document pas
vous pensiez que j'ai extrait des propos
dans le cadre d'un autre débat nous nous
parlions vous parliez à l'époque
d'environnement avant vous n'étiez pas
sénateur
moi j'étais encore moins ministre si
j'ose dire mais je pense que vous allez
vous allez vous reconnaitre vous dites
certains dans certains sceptiques ils y
ont vu une forme de désarmement
unilatéral dans la compétition
économique pourtant nul ne conteste
aujourd'hui notamment au travers des
effets de plus en plus tangible du
réchauffement climatique que l'humanité
doit inventer de nouveaux modes de
développement pour assurer son avenir
donc le temps est arrivé nous avions la
charte
nous estimons qu'elle n'est pas
suffisamment complète notamment sur la
question des règlements climatique nous
estimons également et je les dis je vais
déjà exprimé à plusieurs reprises que sa
porte est nous semble insuffisante c'est
pourquoi nous allons vers ce texte le
nouveau vous disiez aussi à l'époque
monsieur sénateurs et je ne peux que
vous rejoindre que vous estimiez qu'il
était bien logique au fond que la france
fasse partie des nation pionnière et je
voudrais vous dire de ce point de vue
que l'inscription dans notre
constitution à l'article 1er de ce que
nous souhaitons inscrire fait de la
france un pays pionnier en la matière
peu de pays dans leurs constitutions ma
connaissance pas de pays d'ailleurs mais
je peux être démentie on tue sept
cette audace qui n'est pas qu'une audace
c'est la première remarque que que je
souhaitais faire de nature contextuel
pardonnez moi donc monsieur le sénateur
wattebled les effets juridiques je les
ai expliqué a à plusieurs reprises il
faut concilier les principes sans mettre
certains principes au dessus des autres
ensuite s'est posé la question de
biodiversité de biodiversité et de
diversité biologique
en réalité le code de l'environnement
précise déjà que ces termes sont
synonymes
donc il n'ya pas de difficulté il
fallait il fallait en choisir un nous
avons choisi celui-là je suis également
évidemment interrogé monsieur sénateur
bailly encore que je ne sais pas si vous
avez renoncé finalement à votre question
sur l'articulation de l'article 6 de la
charte de l'environnement et du projet
de révision constitutionnelle ne
travaille pas de concurrents je vous
rayon si vous y répondez j'en serais
être très heureux mais ce genre de
question que je vous ai posé à près d'un
an mais celle d'après j'y viens je sais
qu'elle vous taraude
c'est bon il ya ni concurrence des
contradictions entre le projet de
révision constitutionnelle en réalité la
charte de l'environnement
mais il ya une complémentarité projet de
loi constitutionnelle ne vise en effet
en aucun cas à concurrencer ou à
remplacer la sarthe a instauré en
réalité un véritable principe d'action
en faveur de l'environnement à la charge
pour lui dire la charge de nouvelles des
pouvoirs publics
l'autre question qui est beaucoup plus
politique celle-là oui alors d'abord je
vous dis un peu comment les choses se
sont passées à l'assemblée nationale et
comment on va présenter des versions
différentes de la situation
en plein débat le député e aubert tout
repos pour le site et le 10 mai en fin
vous savez bien vous fait tout ça pour
rien moi j'ai pas le goût de l'effort
inutiles comme vous sans doute monsieur
le sénateur vous battez comme un
déchaîné vous vous êtes arquebouté sur
garantir et lutter mais vous savez bien
que ça ne sert à rien parce que le sénat
ne va pas voter ça agit mais bon mais
comment on dit ça et pourquoi vous me le
dites
et là il me dit parce que je les lui
dans le jdd c'est ce qu'a exprimé le
président larcher
si c'est fabuleux autre conception de la
navette parlementaire au fond c'est un
premier vote à l'assemblée nationale et
la lecture du jdd
ok mais je persiste parce que je suis
opiniâtre comme vous je vous c'est cette
qualité est donc le texte est voté et là
on me dit mais maintenant
vous allez voir vous battre au
référendum et on dit partout dans la
presse mais moi j'ai suivi le conseil je
n'avais pas lu le jdd dont j'ai lu toute
la presse avec beaucoup d'attention pour
que d'intérêts et là j'ai vu que
monsieur robert disait mais maintenant
le sénat va voter puis on se retrouvera
au référendum
donc je lui ai dit rendez vous rendez
vous dans les urnes bien sûr que je ne
souhaite pas que l'on bouge le texte
pourquoi je souhaite pas mais je pense
que monsieur sénateur bailly quand vous
avez vous-même présenter votre
proposition de loi tendant à modifier la
constitution avec monsieur sénateurs et
ayew vous étiez attachés aux mots que
vous aviez imaginé mais là c'est plus
que ça c'est une convention citoyenne
d'abord c'est le président de la
république c'est ensuite le conseil
d'état qui nous renforcent au fond dans
l'idée que il faut aller loin et qu' il
faut présenter une une quasi obligation
bon que me demandez-vous encore ben je
lui ai dit tout à l'heure si vous amendé
le texte n'est pas moins le législateur
c'est vous à ce stade vous le ferez mais
moi je souhaite garantir parce que
garantir avec le regard que porte le
conseil d'état et qui nous convient nous
souhaitons garantir et lutter avec le
regard que porte le conseil d'état nous
souhaitons lutter donc si nous abandon
vous arrêtez tout ce n'est pas ce que
j'ai dit monsieur le sénateur bas j'ai
dit que vous étiez le législateur jeudi
par ailleurs que je ne suis pas le
président de la république ce qui ne
vous a pas échappé
il m'avait échappé vous n'étiez pas
sénateurs avant 2011 mais il n'a pas pu
vous échapper je ne suis pas président
de la république
[Applaudissements]
si monsieur le ministre comme disent les
procureurs à chaque jour suffit sa peine
monsieur le sénateur bas et nous allons
monsieur le ministre continue et notre
peine pour essayer d'avancer dans nos
débats en donnant la parole tout de
suite à monsieur alain richard il est là
où est en visio tarvisio
suis je suis en visio monsieur a bien ri
quand vous avez la parole le ministre
elle salue à nouveau les collègues aux
plus de ce que j'ai salué ce matin je
m'accroche sur cette expression que vous
répété à plusieurs reprises monsieur le
ministre qui est allé plus loin donc une
un équilibre des normes
constitutionnelles issus du texte actuel
et notamment de la charte qui ne paraît
pas satisfaisant au président et au
gouvernement
je voudrais faire un pas de côté pour me
demander s'il faut invoquer l'avis du
conseil d'état dans ce débat on s'est
dit ah n'ai qu'un conseil et il a un
rôle forcément titre est retenue en
matière institutionnelle
mais lorsqu'un conseil d'état emplois
dans son avis l'expression quasi
obligation de résultat
je ne suis pas sûr qu'il en fasse une
préconisation ma lecture plutôt qu'il en
fait un avertissement ou je ne voudrais
pas qu'on se pare de l'expression
figurant dans cet avis comme un argument
forcément positif à l'égard du terme de
garantir mais ce qui me préoccupe c'est
avec cette volonté de faire coexister
une norme de fond qui est dans l'article
1er avec les normes de fond qui sont
dans la charte et en disant à l'article
1er va plus loin donc ça veut dire que
dans la conciliation de ces principes
ce qui est sûr dans l'article premier
aura une prééminence je reprends la
question de philippe bas ça ne
surprendra pas est-ce que l' équilibre
soigneusement délibéré à l'époque qui
figure dans l'article 6 de la charte
reste un équilibre ou est ce que on
regarde ce qui pousse pire et notamment
le contrôle du conseil constitutionnel
jusqu'ici à savoir un équilibre entre
préservation progrès social et
développement économique
est-ce que cet équilibre est modifié moi
ce que j'entends est-ce que ce qui
résultera des travaux préparatoires si
ce texte est à noter c'est que
l'équilibré il est changé sinon je ne
vois pas où est les faits
en fonction du terme de garanties et
dans ce changement que j'entrevois de la
hiérarchie des normes
il me semble que le contrôle
constitutionnel sur le contenu et loi va
changer et va changer dans un sens
d'exigence cris de mon point de vue
potentiellement d'exigence
déstabilisatrices par rapport à la
conduite d'une politique de
décarbonation de l'économie et de
renforcement de la biodiversité qui
pourrait rencontrer ainsi les obstacles
très substantiel vous donne deux
exemples et je vous demande si vous
l'acceptez un bref commentaire sur les
deux exemples elle je pense nous avons
adopté ça a été laborieux
une disposition qui introduit une
dérogation dans une loi antérieure de
protection de la biodiversité que je me
reproche de la barre beauté d'ailleurs
car elle ne prévoit elle pas cette
possibilité de dérogation alors qu'il
était déjà flagrant à l'époque ils en
auraient besoin
donc nous avons été cette dérogation
prêts partiels à j'insiste pour dire sa
peau c'est 3 % de surfaces cultivables
l'essentiel de l'objectif de réduction
des épandages et bien atteint mais
évidemment la norme de finale le textile
satire supplémentaires qui dit banon
pour 3%
on donne une dérogation d'ailleurs à
titre temporaire le conseil
constitutionnel elle dit
c'est conforme à la constitution y
compris à ce que tu la charte
si l'article garanties portent aussi sur
la biodiversité est introduit est-ce que
vous pensez que la décision du conseil
constitutionnel soit la mamie il me
semble que le plus loin sur lequel vous
avez insisté il vous débuterez à dire
non
là vous avez votre venue à la protection
de la biodiversité
donc c'est inconstitutionnel par exemple
les articles 47 48 et 49 adopté par
l'assemblée dans la loi climat et
résilience fixe un objectif qui devient
un objectif impératif qui est la loi sur
la réduction des surfaces
artificialisées à bhl qui se traduit par
des normes
durand droit dur qui descendent
jusqu'aux plans locaux d'urbanisme des
communes
donc si on se place dans l'hypothèse
d'une situation dans laquelle commune
est obligé parce que son territoire
urbain est déjà saturée de faire une
extension et elle arrive à le faire par
la procédure légale mais qu'une qpc
s'oppose à cette opération je pense par
exemple à une opération de logement tout
simplement et donc de l'application du
droit au logement la mise en oeuvre
effective du droit au logement ou pour
la réalisation de l'établissement
hospitalier donc la réalisation du droit
à la santé
est-ce que l'inscription du terme
garanti c'est prééminence par rapport
aux autres principes constitutionnels
n'aboutit pas à dire cet os cassés c'est
toi qui ne fait que limiter la
croissance des de l'artificiel
artificialisation du bien devient
inconstitutionnelle parce qu'il faut
l'arrêter complètement
donc j'aimerais avoir votre appréciation
ses conséquences effectives d'un nouveau
droit dans lequel il ya une prééminence
merci monsieur monsieur le ministre
avant de donner la parole à 10 et mohéli
mais je vous rappelle la question de
nicole bonnefoy sûr et bien commun de
référendum
je crois que la réponse n'a pas été
effective sur ce sujet je donne la
parole à didier mandelli merci merci
messieurs les présidents sur le ministre
vous avez en nous présentant ce projet
de loi en fait traduit la commande du
président de la république qui lui-même
traduisez les propositions de la
convention semaine pour le climat enfin
proposition ou recommandations je peux
parler d'injonction en ce en ce sens moi
je met en lumière et notre collègue
alain richard vient d'expliquer un volet
du futur projet de loi climat moi je met
en lumière cette volonté farouche que
vous avez de modifier la constitution
sur ces sujets sur ce sujet précis et le
contenu du projet de loi climat qui à
tout le moins ne recueille pas d'avis de
satisfaction au plus haut niveau puisque
à la fois le haut conseil pour le climat
la convention citoyenne pour le climat
elle même je parle même pas du conseil
d'état qui a émis un avis très réservé
et bien sûr l'ensemble des ong un grand
nombre d'acteurs considère que le projet
de loi climat ne répond qu'à environ 40%
des besoins nécessaires pour atteindre
les objectifs de la cap 21 de paris et
donc je me dis quel décalage entre cette
volonté de modifier la constitution et
la traduction dans un texte qui va nous
arriver très vite également aujourd'hui
à l'assemblée qui en réalité ne traduit
pas aussi fortement cette volonté et
quelle incidence comme notre collègue
alain richard vient d'exprimer sur un
certain nombre de points de ce projet de
loi climat résilience au regard de la
modification de la constitution avec des
effets qui viennent d'être d'être évoqué
donc voila moi je note monsieur le
ministre ce décalage entre cette volonté
que vous avez exprimées à présent des
républiques de modifier la constitution
mais sans pour autant dans le projet le
climat en parallèle
afficher cette même volonté merci
monsieur mandela madame gatel merci
monsieur messieurs les présidents
monsieur le ministre
en préambule je voudrais dire que ici
nul ne conteste l'exigence de préserver
les ressources dont nous avons hérité et
que nous devons transmettre donc et vous
vous l'avez dit il n'y a pas d'un côté
des bienveillant ou des malveillante par
rapport à l'environnement de la même
manière que nul ne conteste l'intérêt de
la participation citoyenne la convention
citoyenne à consulter je pense que les
citoyens qui en étaient membres ont ôté
ont été également informés du fait que
dans la constitution à son plus haut
niveau il y avait un adossée à la
constitution la charte de
l'environnement au même titre que les
droits de l'homme par exemple et on sait
que cette inscription n'est pas sans
conséquence puisqu'il y ait trois
décisions qui ont été prises que vous
connaissez bien
je parlerai de deux décisions la
première qui était celle de
l'interdiction de la fabrication de la
vente ou de l'importation de produits
pharmaceutiques que tes oreilles tu est
contraire aux prescriptions
environnementales de l'europe
ce qui veut dire que la décision qui a
été prise a affirmé la suprématie de
l'intérêt de l'environnement par rapport
à un droit qui est celui de la liberté
d'entreprendre et on a vu plus récemment
une décision qui a trouvé un équilibre
entre la protection de l'environnement
et l'urgence puisque c'est et celle de
l'autorisation quelques-uns de
l'utilisation provisoire de produits
phytosanitaires
donc il y une charte de l'environnement
qui est inscrite dans les principes
constitutionnels qui a permis de montrer
eu son utilité le fait qu'elle était
respectée l'articulation entre plusieurs
principes
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure de
symboles monsieur le
donc les symboles d'un poids c'est le
poids des mots donc en proposant de
l'écrire comme vous le proposez est ce
que cela veut dire que vous estimez
nécessaire que le respect de
l'environnement devient un principe
constitutionnel supérieur à
hiérarchiquement à d'autres principes
alors vous avez dit je reprends vos mots
qu'il s'agissait d'aller un peu plus
loin sans ironie et sans mauvais esprit
monsieur mini-jeux dirait parfois que la
créature dépasse son créateur et alors
qu'on veut aller plus loin il se peut
qu'on gèle l'action des collectivités et
j'aimerais aborder notre échange à
partir du point de vue d'un élu local
cela a été un peu évoqué tout à l'heure
imaginons que dans une collectivité il y
à une élaboration de paix lui qui amène
les élus a décidé de geler entre
guillemets va % de la surface de la
commune et puis puisque notre ère est à
la judiciarisation une association de
citoyens très favorable à
l'environnement se constitue et dit
monsieur le maire vous n'avez pas
garanti enfin vous n'avez pas garanti
venez pas respecté la constitution
puisque au lieu de 30% vous auriez du
jeu les 50% des ter et deux autres
exemples c'est un jour l'état ou une
région estime nécessaire pour pour
favoriser le désenclavement d'une région
de faire une ligne ferroviaire
y'aurait-il la garantie du principe que
vous voulez inscrire et enfin les parcs
éoliens qui aujourd'hui font l'objet de
beaucoup de contestations ne vaut-il pas
être aussi condamné dont vraiment maquis
soi n'est pas piégeuse monsieur le
ministre mais je pars du principe ou de
la question du point de vue d'un élu
local que j'étais et dont nous sommes
nombreux à être ici et à
qui nous avons à rendre des comptes en
tant que chambre des territoires je vous
remercie
si madame gatel ce 2010 quand vous
voulez permettez monsieur le président
de la commission des lois répondre à
monsieur sénateur richert parce que sa
question en réalité est une question
multiples d'abord on parle ans de quasi
obligation je je je partage l'avis de
monsieur le sénateur je sais pas où il
est monsieur le sénateur richard voit
pas pas grave il a coupé sa si vous
vouliez plus d'accord elle a très bien
ensemble sur le sénateur oui en parlant
de quasi obligation de résultat le
conseil d'état dit monsieur sénateur
richard donne un avertissement je pense
qu'il a raison je pense que c'est vrai
et le gouvernement entend cet
avertissement et assume le choix il
entend renforcer la protection de
l'environnement
mais le projet de loi constitutionnelle
va en effet changer les équilibres
pourquoi mais parce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure il y à une distinction qui peut
être fait entre un objectif à valeur
constitutionnelle est une règle
constitutionnelle qui elle un caractère
impératif donc un certain nombre de
principes et valeurs constitutionnelles
vont se retrouver
d'une part en équilibre mais il faut le
dire il faut le dire parce que c'est
extrêmement important sans que l'un soit
privilégiée par rapport à l'autre et ça
me permet d'ailleurs de répondre à
madame la sénatrice gatel il s'agit pas
de concurrencer de concurrence entre
entre les principes il s'agit d'
équilibre différent et les pouvoirs
publics
évidemment vont pouvoir choisir en toute
connaissance de cause
ça n'est pas ça n'est pas la fin de
l'entreprise qui peut lui on pourra
continuer à rouler en voiture je veux
dire que il
faute assumer des libertés qui sont des
libertés à valeur constitutionnelle sans
que l'on puisse dire que celles qui sont
relatives à l'emprisonnement viennent
d'écraser toute les autres se donner un
exemple simple j'ai dit dans mon
discours
ça mérite d'être développé gelé
développer à l'assemblée nationale
imaginons demain que ce qu'à dieu
pardonnez moi ce qu'à dieu ne plaise
évidemment nous ayons une une pandémie
une nouvelle une autre pandémie qui
exige la mise en oeuvre de de
fabrication chimiques extraordinairement
polluantes
est ce que vous pensez franchement que
la santé va passer derrière la
protection environnementale
sûrement pas il y a effectivement un
rééquilibrage mais c'est un
rééquilibrage qui n'instaure dans notre
texte strictement aucune hiérarchie des
valeurs constitutionnelles et les
pouvoirs publics ont naturellement
naturellement naturellement mais bien
bien sûr quand vous évoquez tout à
l'heure et là on est sur le terrain
torride territoriales si j'ose dire ça
n'est pas anormal que la question ne
soit posée ici au sénat mais tout à
l'heure monsieur le sénateur vous voyez
déjà posé la question je vous ai dit
d'abord que c'est le législateur qui
étaient tenues mais les collectivités
locales
en réalité ce n'est pas tout à fait la
même chose sur le terrain de l'as sur le
terrain constitutionnel j'ai expliqué
cela tout à l'heure en revanche
effectivement que vous avez aussi la
possibilité d'envisager je ne sais
quelle construction dont on pourra dire
qu'elle pollue ya aussi l'intérêt public
il yad'autres valeurs constitutionnelles
qui viennent évidemment qui vient
évidemment percuté celle là le tout
c'est de garantir au mieux
voilà le le change du test ne faisons
pas dire à ce texte
de grâce que le principe constitutionnel
que nous entendons mettre en exergue
dans l'article premier vient écraser
tous les autres ça n'est pas ça du tout
le sens
d'ailleurs je redis que
ce texte ne vient pas contredire la
charte
il vient compléter la charte
monsieur monsieur sénateurs mon délire
vous me critiquer à la fois en dix ans
la loi climat est un décalage avec la
volonté de modifier la constitution
moi je vous retourne l'argument et je
vous dis on peut pas critiquer la loi
climat au motif qu'elle serait
insuffisante et contester la volonté de
réhausser l'obligation constitutionnelle
que nous souhaitons que nous souhaitons
mettre en place et le moment n'est pas
venu ici
le moment n'est pas venu ici mais je
pense que dans le débat parlementaire
il y aura bien un moment où il faudra
que je le fasse de rappeler ce que nous
avons fait pour lutter contre
l'environnement
qu'est-ce que je dois dire d'autre et
qui doit encore répondre pardonnez-moi à
madame pardonnez-moi mais oui vous avez
raison voire donnez-moi sur la notion de
bien commun est une notion ces notions
qui a déjà été évoqué dans le cadre des
débats évidemment les gouvernements
estime que cette notion n'est pas
suffisante et pas suffisante ne
pardonnez moi pas suffisamment précises
pour figurer dans la constitution
bon la constitution c'est évidemment
tout le monde l'a dit tout le monde le
sait la règle commune et il faut un
consensus sur le mot et sur leur portée
ce n'est pas ironique quand je dis cela
évidemment nous nous avons choisi un
certain nombre de mots vous le savez
j'essaierai de m'y tenir
mais il ya deux de deux questions qui
sont qui sont revenus c'est le principe
de non régression dont on a beaucoup
parlé en cas des débats à l'assemblée
nationale
la question des biens communs également
la question des biens communs nous
estimons que la définition n'est pas
suffisamment clair pour figurer dans la
constitution
merci monsieur le ministre je crois que
monsieur richard a demandé la parole
vous donne la parole mais simplement
pour essayer de bien préciser où nous en
sommes tout à l'heure monsieur le
ministre vous avez dit que s'il
s'agissait de substituer un principe de
valeur constitutionnelle vu leurs règles
constitutionnelles
je ne crois pas m'être trompé en vous
écoutant et donc c'est là et vous avez
employé
je resterai à plusieurs reprises c'est
tout à fait représentatif le terme de
plus loin donc il me semble bien qu'il
en résulte contrairement à ce que vous
disiez à la fin de votre propos une
hiérarchie entre cette règle là et les
autres principes de valeur
constitutionnelle et donc l'equilibre
non quantifiée qui figure dans l'article
6 de la charte
il me semble que s'il y a un changement
c'est bien pour le modifier cet
équilibre et pour faire prévaloir
l'exigence de garanties aussi bien sur
la biodiversité que sur le climat sur la
prise en compte
donc il me semble que rencontre le début
de votre propos est la démonstration
vous présentiez à l'instant il ya un
glissement et je crains que ce soit ou
même un peu le noeud du problème
si celui de monsieur philippe bas et
ensuite monsieur le ministre merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je vous prends au mot aller
plus loin oui mais où
dites nous où deuxièmement vous avez dit
tout à l'heure pour nous rassurer et
peut-être est-ce une perche que vous
nous tende et il faut garantir au mieux
la préservation de l'environnement et de
la diversité biologique en conciliant
cette garantie avec d'autres principes
si jamais un sénateur me de moi par
exemple présenté un amendement disant
garantir au mieux
puis-je en déduire que vous seriez
d'accord avec cet amendement
[Rires]
vous avez la parole
et l'article 46 de monsieur monsieur
sénateurs
je vais répondre à monsieur sénateur
richard mais je vous réponde avant
tampon en bulle quand l'article 46
garantit la protection de la santé
voulait également qu'on modifie les
choses que j'ai eu des tas de monde dont
un où je pense que vous avez suivi les
débats à l'assemblée nationale
les crevettes les éleveurs les langues
régionales le voile
j'en passe et des meilleurs jeux je n'ai
pas tous ici moi j'ai essayé de
circonscrire le débat en disant non mais
on parle pas de ça voilà et donc ça
donnait quelque chose d'assez cocasses
qui j'en suis sûr n'aura pas lieu du
tout au sénat qu'est ce que ça donnait
au fond on introduisait un amendement
sur le voile et moi je disais mais je
veux pas qu'on parle de ça ont
circonscrit et l'harmoniser mais alors
le voile ne vous intéresse pas et
l'immigration ne vous intéresse pas et
le terrorisme ne vous intéresse pas
monsieur le ministre
or c'était c'est très curieux cette
façon de faire parce qu'au fond moi
j'étais bloqué sur mon texte et c'était
bien légitime mais ça permettait aux
parlementaires de développer chacun leur
sujet pour ne pas dire parfois leurs
marottes
moi je restais quoi naturellement et on
insistait toujours pour des loyers ces
sujets n'intéresse pas le gouvernement
il n'intéresse que nous donc je suis
certain que nous n'aurons pas ce type de
débat au sénat j'en suis absolument
convaincu mais je dois vous rappeler que
l'article 46 du préambule garantit la
protection de la santé
voilà pas au mieux la loi ne peut pas
être bavard garantie ça veut dire
garantir au mieux ça ne peut pas
garantir ça ne peut pas être garantie
rompirent monsieur le sénateur dont je
je je je n'imagine pas qu'un amendement
comme celui là soient déposées garantir
c'est garantir monsieur monsieur
sénateur richard pardon ce que ce que je
veux expliquer mais sans doute me
suis-je mal fait comprendre
aujourd'hui c'est un objectif d'intérêt
général qui n'est pas la règle
constitutionnelle et vous le savez donc
effectivement effectivement ça
this is it c'est des règles
constitutionnelles 5 le conseil l'a
jugée non mais j'entends bien mais moi
si j'entends bien mais vous savez par
exemple que sur le fondement de la
charte on peut difficilement aller faire
une qpc
voilà donc nous on veut aller plus loin
c'est ça notamment
attendez je veux être complet sur cette
question c'est ça pour nous aller plus
loin mais en même temps nous allons plus
loin
nous ne souhaitons pas créer de
hiérarchie entre les autres règles à
valeur constitutionnelle
voilà ce que nous disons tout simplement
il faudra des conciliations j'ai pris
tout à l'heure l'exemple en matière de
santé publique
demain il faut qu'on construise au
préjudice avec une pollution qui serait
très très important je ne sais quel
matériau nouveau point d'ailleurs parlé
des masques est ce que on s'interdit de
le faire au motif que ça abîme
l'environnement ça laisse beaucoup de
liberté puisqu'il n'y a pas de
hiérarchie entre les valeurs mais il ya
un certain nombre de ya un certain
nombre il ya un certain nombre de
valeurs qui maintenant sont nouvelles
effectivement et notamment la protection
de l'environnement la biodiversité et le
dérèglement climatique
[Musique]